foreign
what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg here today John how's it going
quantastic guys we are going to talk today about
the Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania mid credit
scene when I said in our non-spoiler review
that it felt like an SNL sketch there's a lot
of question marks to why I said that and now
while I see that there's a lot of people who
love this mid-credit scene and there's a lot of
people who really don't like the mid credit scene
as well I want to say specifically why today
we did not really jive with this mid-credit
scene the post-credits scene good nice clip that
they played but the mid credit scene was the one
that definitely raised some eyebrows we just
got to go into it's the first order of business
if you're here leave a like or a dislike or a
comment just engage with the video in some way
who cares how you do it just be honest now let's
dive right into it first thing I want to say is
yes I understand I said in a non-spoiler and I'll
say it again the context of what this med credit
scene represents and what it's setting up totally
cool in fact before this movie came out this was
a big theorized what might be in the mid-credits
scene and sure enough it came to fruition so I was
like yeah I'm not surprised to see it but when it
played out I'm talking specifically about how the
scene is handled that's what had me the most
concerned and what made me cringe kind of the
most when watching this film and had some audible
laughs at her screening at the end of this movie
not gonna do a full ending explainer recap here
King gets taken down by a bunch of ants that uh
were set up really late in the film we could take
him down by a bunch of ants and then eventually
gets fully taken down by Ant-Man and wasp who gets
like stuck in the quantum realm but according to
this mid-credits scene he's dead he's dead because
in this mid credit scene what do we see we see
Rama Tut we see a mortise and I think it's either
like Prime gang or Scarlet Centurion or or maybe
some new futuri king that ramata does say must
upset you that you weren't the one to kill him but
they do confirm that the exiled one is dead now
when they first start showing up on screen I did
not think it was cool it actually read as goofy
and the reason why is this when you're seeing them
again contextually it sounds like it would be the
most awesome thing in the world when you look at
what Jonathan Majors did in Loki season one as um
he who remains it's really effective has a lot of
presence very ominous there's a real mood it's
striking and he really left an impression and
then in Kane the Conqueror in quantumania
same thing very different portrayal fully
realize three-dimensional character but then the
second you start cutting to these three different
Kings it doesn't feel lived in it looks like
Jonathan majors in costume in makeup it's the
first time it doesn't feel like he's being Kang
but acting I could really feel like he's acting
that's what I meant by SNL sketch of where you put
an actor and costume and makeup and they're doing
some surface notes of things so it feels like
they're playing versus being didn't really evoke
a mood it didn't really have a solid tone on it it
just read as cheesy and kind of like a Sony post
credit scene to me in that regard I'm not even
talking about the second half of what happened
in this physical scene I was talking about the
introduction of this while they're saying setting
it up like oh yeah people on Earth are beginning
to touch the Multiverse and they can threaten all
the work we've done it's the interaction between
them where I did not feel like I was looking at
three different Kings I felt like they definitely
had Jonathan Majors film three different times and
they splice it together it was like watching
Mike Myers and Austin Powers or Eddie Murphy
and The Nutty Professor Norbit films that's more
akin to what it felt like in that moment than it
did feeling like I'm watching three completely
different fully realized characters and that's
where I was leading to cringe but then they
say I'm summing them all or some [__] like
that tell them what happened John well I mean
yeah then you you know they exit this little
chamber that they're in and they go into this big
arena where there are multiple Kings appearing
you know teleporting in there are already a ton
of them surrounding this Coliseum just cheering
and hooting and hollering and awaiting the next
phase of their plan now that the exiled one has
been vanquished so to speak it really does
continue with this weirdly comedic sense of
of either abandon or just not that much time and
effort put into the sequence because yeah it does
feel like they just pulled a bunch of costumes
off a rack and said hey yeah just you know do a
bunch of different things whatever comes to mind
and we'll just drop them all in and it does like
Frat Boys exactly and and the thing is most all
of them are behaving it it almost reminded me
of like watching Space Jam a new Legacy in a way
where you have yeah just like a bunch of copies
of a person in the background they're all just
kind of like behaving what appears to be sort of
the same way so it undercuts the variance quality
and it makes it feel like a cartoon in a way that
doesn't suit things because if you look at the
original comic book panel there is a Whimsy to
this whole Council of Kings this Coliseum of kings
and there is I think room for quirkiness within
that but it just yeah it just feels silly rather
than quirky or you know imposing or anything like
that and it feels like you're just in a Green's
green Warehouse rather than some otherworldly
environment or you know some great Citadel where
big machinations are being planned out you know
the introduction in the comic is very different
to the moment that they are definitely hearkening
too because the king that we're following in that
comic you know he's first brought pretty much into
a very dark room and he's like who am I surrounded
by who's there and then it's revealed and there's
like a [__] ton of kings that strikes something
menacing even though it can look a little bit
silly at first it's like oh this is a shock and
versus what they do here which just played goofy
to me it kind of reads into the issues that I had
with the last parts of this film with King the
Conqueror in the finale of this film to me what
makes Kang so threatening is not the fact that
he's a super powered individual it's the fact that
he's a Super Brain individual he's a highly highly
intelligent that's where a lot of his Mastery of
time and being able to navigate to get a leg up on
foreshadowing oh there's always like 50 billion
steps ahead and whatnot and he's just become so
goon Reliant and in the way this mid-credits
scene made it feel is like okay so the threat
is not really a king or a couple of Kings it's the
fact there's a large quantity of them there should
just be like one badass like having multiple Kings
is great I think that's a great call and there's
a lot of story you can do with that and a lot of
great things you can pull into enhance the threat
in the Menace absolutely there should be a primary
King though not just meaning Prime I'm talking
about there should be a primary who is just that
much of a high level Evil Genius who was truly the
embodiment of the Conqueror and that's what you
or feel threatened by not the fact that there's a
[__] ton of them and then 99 of them feel like a
bunch of dumbasses who are just like oh yeah yeah
because then you you cut there and you're like you
guys you guys are the people we're gonna have to
be dealing with and afraid of for the rest of the
phases of this because from the outside going into
the movie it certainly seems like this is the
stage to introduce the new big bad and I don't
mind a subversion you know I don't mind leaving
a movie going oh damn it's not what I expected
however this doesn't give you anything new exactly
to expect and when you think back to Kevin feige
being like Oh man all the different iterations of
Jonathan Majors is going to be amazing that could
still work but right now this doesn't you know
the three you spend time with hearing them talk
doesn't give you hope for seeing them again in
any kind of way that'll leave an impact other than
silliness and the arena doesn't give you any other
options either to me I think a lot of people are
ending this film going it's okay that this King
the Conqueror went down I don't agree with how he
went down oh just bottom line I just don't agree
with it all right I don't care if he's not the
main bad King even a variance of King the conquer
so bad has been exiled he shouldn't be going down
like this you see him in he who remains in Loki
season one and then you know he he dies you know
people are like don't worry guys don't worry he's
not the real big bad kings don't worry the real
big bad kings go and then he dies in quantumania
and if your people are like don't worry the real
big bad kings coming and then they have this
post-credits scene which was a really good
post-credit scene Mobius has a line in there but
he's like this is him I thought he was supposed
to be like super scary and people are laughing
in the theaters it's a funny line but it also
made me go that's how I felt about the mid-credits
scene that's what this movie should have made me
feel like he should be I should be feeling like
how Loki's feeling in the scene but it said I'm
feeling like how Mobius is feeling in that scene
and so it's like you watch a variance of Kang
die enough it makes it not scary anymore I'm not a
fan of these the mid credit scene I don't like the
execution of it and the idea of More Kings coming
there's still time to improve upon it to truly
make it something menacing because some of those
Daniels you know stuff like fine I'll do it myself
in Age of Ultron that was Goofy but this this is
like exceptionally I'm working for me honestly
yeah well there's a whole scene of goofiness
versus a shot but hey that's just our opinion what
did you guys think did you love it did it excite
you did you think it was silly did you think it
was scary what were your feelings on it leave
your thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
leave a like keep a lookout for our spoiler talk
that we are doing this saturday see y'all soon
[Music]